[Music]
just interrupting today's edition of
counting the cast you can see that are
down to zero calm if you want to watch
the rest of it to bring you breaking
news from Sudan these protesters in the
street in support of President Omar
al-bashir former President Obama Shia
who we have just learned has been
sentenced to two years in prison on
financial irregularity charges the
background to this of course Ashiya was
30 years in charge of Sudan he was
removed after the protests in April and
since has had charges brought against
him on issues of corruption and
financial irregularities to the point of
apparently having 130 million dollars
worth of foreign currency stuffed in
suitcases in his own house well the
protesters are out I should say his
supporters are out on the street inside
the courtroom we had been watching the
judge bring down his verdict a little
bit earlier Norman R Bashir himself was
in court for that Hibbert Morgan is a
correspondent in Khartoum following
developments Heber bring us up-to-date
well c'mon this verdict has been
expected for the past three weeks the
judge had already said this day December
14th as the date that a verdict will be
issued against the former president and
his sentencing now there are protests in
several parts of the capital khartoum
that has been helpful by supporters of
the former ruling party which was
dissolved two weeks ago they're saying
that that's what is happening right now
the political transition the political
process that is going on in the country
is not something that they support and
that they do not favor they do not want
and do not recognize the dissolving of
the former ruling party and that this
whole trial is a sham that is something
we've heard from the defense team when
they came out just a couple of minutes
ago they're saying that the judge is
biased that the judge has political
motivations that his leaning towards the
forces of freedom and change coalition
and that they do not recognize the
verdicts and will appeal some of them
came out chanting against the judges
chanting in support of the former
president and they say that they will go
on to join the protest in the other
parts of the color of the Capitol to
show the support and condemn the the
decision that has been taken the verdict
that has been taken by the judge okay so
I feel this is an important point that
you've made here but the fact that Omar
al-bashir does have support it's easy to
cast our minds back to April and to
remember the protests which removed him
from office but clearly he still has
plenty of support there let's not forget
to come out that the guy has been ruling
that country for 30 years so yes he does
have a certain amount of supporters in
the capital khartoum and various other
parts of the country the turnout so far
if you compare it to the protest that
happened in December and that went on to
oust him in April and continued after
that in a setting in front of army
headquarters if you compare the two it
doesn't look like it is as much as the
number of people who came out in protest
of former President Omar al-bashir
nevertheless they were concerned and
there still remain to be concerned about
the people who call for today's protests
the army issued a statement last night
and announced that it will be closing
roads that is leading to its
headquarters here in the capital
Khartoum and various parts of the
country making sure that there will be
no one approaching the
headquarters to try to stage a citizen
similar to the one that happened in
April that outside former President
Hamid Bashir but that has not stopped
his supporters they're saying that they
will continue to protest just a few
minutes ago just a few just less than 30
minutes ago actually some of them came
close to the court before they were
dispersed by the police are guarding the
courthouse here ahead of the verdict
that was issued just a few minutes ago
okay just to clarify here but before we
move on the the this two years that he
gets in jail what's what what charges
that specifically for because there were
a few different charges in this first
sort of phase well he has been charged
with illicit financial gains corruption
bribery and illegal possession of
foreign currencies that is something
that the judge before issuing his
verdict explained what what actions come
with them if he's found guilty which he
has just been found guilty but these are
not the only charges facing the former
president come out just a few days ago
he was interrogated on charges of outing
the democratically elected government in
1989 that was the coup that brought
former President Omar al-bashir to power
he's also been charged with inciting and
killing of protesters that charge was
directed against him by the prosecutor
by the public prosecutor in May for
inciting and killing protesters since
the protests began in December and we're
talking at this point of the number of
more than a hundred people so even with
today's verdict issued by this judge
there are still short cases there are
some legal hearings that we should be
expect respecting in the coming weeks
against the former president okay and
actually just say there for me here
because I want to expand on that a
little bit more for our viewers as
Hibbert says the trials about corruption
and legal position there's still more to
come but let's not forget that Alma
Beshear faces a litany of additional
charges if you go back to 2009 the
International Criminal Court charged him
with two counts of war crimes and five
counts of crimes against humanity that
was for his role in the war in Darfur
which started back in 2003 300,000
people died there another 3 million were
displaced a year later the same court in
The Hague brought three counts of
genocide that was also for Darfur
then in May this year and that's after
he was deposed of course Sudan's public
prosecutor
charged him with inciting and
participating in the killing of
protesters activists say at least a
hundred people had been killed and then
in November he and several of his aides
that were charged for plotting and
carrying out the 1989 coup that actually
brought him to power Hibbert just as I
read all of those out there you realize
there is so much more against Omar
al-bashir I guess the prosecutor is
going after the things which he knows he
can get him on or has a better chance of
getting it on now but there is still a
lot a lot of stuff out there yes indeed
there are so a lot of stuff earth and
it's not just the western region of
Darfur people protesters who have
toppled him are saying that there also
were crimes that happened in southern
regions of Blue Nile and South Kordofan
they don't want to see the former
president being held to account for
those charges as well the judge had said
that it goes one step at a time that
this is the first chart that has been
brought against him but that in the
coming weeks and the coming months we
will be seeing our trials and hearings
with regards to the other charges the
charges of our staying a democratic
democratically elected government in
1989 and the inciting and participating
in the killing of protesters now what is
not clear is where does the work crimes
and crimes against humanity that
happened in the region of Darfur Falls
the the Attorney General came out and
said that this is the this is not
history jurisdiction this is not very
restriction that there is a public
prosecutor and the public prosecutor
said that they will try to hold the
former president to account for those
charges actually investigating but one
thing they said is that they're not
going to hand him over to the
International Criminal Court that's
something victims of the war crimes in
Darfur have been calling for for the
past few months they're saying that any
procession any legal procession any
trial held here in Sudan is something
they will not recognize because they
feel that they will not be given the
justice they deserve okay let's just
pause for a second looking at pictures
on screen now of the Omar Bashir
supporters in Khartoum in support of the
former Sudanese president who if you're
just joining us we have learned has been
sentenced to two years in prison on
charges of financial irregularities
yes two years in prison and financial
irregularity this is also including the
case of him having suitcases in his
house which was stuffed with millions
hundreds of millions in foreign currency
there is plenty of support as we see
inhibit was telling us earlier that a
man who was in power for 30 years is
obviously still going to have a large
base of support and these are the people
who are saying they want to challenge
what's happened today Hibbert what about
the other side of the coin the
protesters the ones who brought down the
president back in April is their voice
still loud in Khartoum and in Sudan
these days well they have been calling
for justice even before the date of this
verdict had been said they were saying
that there are so many crimes that
happen throughout the period of 30 years
now that is something we have been
hearing from them since the beginning of
the protest they've been chanting for
freedom peace and justice this is one of
their three slogans that they came out
to it and they've been saying that if
the former president is not held to
account then they would feel that their
revolution is incomplete now their focus
mostly has been on the protesters who
have been killed since the process began
in December but then people as I said
before people from Jaffa are saying that
this this is a time now the time has
come for the former president to be
pride of his crime especially because
the judge said that once the former
president was ousted on the 11th of
April any immunity that he had with him
has been automatically dropped so he
could be tried for any crime he was
initially sentenced to 10 years in
prison that has been less than two two
years because of his age being over 70
but protesters now are going to have to
or rather protesters that came to the
streets chanting anti-government
protests that eventually led to his
outing are going to have to wait and see
what comes next they want to know if the
ability if the legal system here in
Sudan will move on after the verdicts
issued to try him for the other crimes
that they say is the main reason why
this country is in turmoil yeah I'm
trying to decide here whether this
verdict today will be seen as a victory
or not for the people who asked it or
Mantova sure I mean they want not only
him held responsible but the whole
regime and everything that was connected
to him responsible it's a guilty verdict
but it's only two years in and I'm
seeing some
ports in a rehabilitation facility
possibly yes it may not go very far in
terms of satisfying the people who have
taken to the streets for the past few
months now let's remember they have
gotten some satisfaction when two weeks
ago the sovereign council and the
Council of Ministers issued a decree
dissolving and disbanding the former
ruling party in dismantling it and
seizing all its assets they got more
satisfaction when just last night the
sovereign council issued a decree
basically dissolving all the labor
unions those were unions that were
established during the reign of former
President Omar al-bashir and which its
members were affiliated to the former
ruling party so to a certain degree they
have gotten some kind of satisfaction or
some level of satisfaction but they have
also been calling for just as in terms
of what happened in the south and in the
southern regions of Brunei and South
Kordofan
they've been calling for justice in the
western region of Darfur so they want to
see more steps being taken for them this
is not enough and they're concerned that
this legal system the new Attorney
General the new head of judiciary the
new lawyers that have been appointed may
not be enough to counter the the lawyers
that have been in place for the past
thirty years and who are put in place by
the former regime and they say that
until they see steps being taken him
being held to account for those crimes
that's when they'll know that they are
on the right track okay but just take a
break for now I doing a tremendous job
for us they're keeping us up-to-date
with what's going on in Khartoum today
I'll just remind viewers who might be
just joining us the head of the news
hour at ten hundred hours GMT that the
breaking news we've got the president of
the former President of Sudan Omar
al-bashir olestra let's have a listen to
this moment
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so some maybe I won't say chaotic scenes
in the court there but certainly very
vocal yet to actually find out if those
are Beshear supporters or protesters
against him but regardless the former
president of Sir Norman / Shearer has
been sentenced to two years in prison
well it was a 10-year sentence it's
reduced to two years in some sort of
facility whether it be prison or
directional facility for financial
irregularities his supporters are
outside they say that this is unfair
that it's simply going after the old
regime which was ousted back in April
and there is plenty of support out there
for Omar al-bashir Jonas Horner with us
now at the Doha forum he is the deputy
director for the Horn of Africa
senior analyst Vista down at
International Crisis Group thanks for
your time Jonas just as this news is
coming through what's your take on it
the fact that he has been found guilty
yes but it seems a pretty mild
sentencing
yes it is Martha I think all this has
required a lot of political
soft-pedaling from the transitional
government the evocative nature of this
this trial is has meant that
particularly the civilian government led
by Abdullah handbook has need to be very
needed to be very careful about how it's
managed this there's still a lot of NCP
support within Sudan and and at the same
time you know the military retains a lot
of NCP supporters the NCP itself has had
most in many of its supporters from the
countryside into Khartoum for for this
to in a bit of a show of force to show
that they're not indeed a spent force in
Sudan but yes I think the financial
crimes version of this Basheer's trial
here is is perhaps a way to front-load
some of the some of the less
controversial charges that Bashar faces
but does does it give them a starting
point then a jumping-off point for going
after the bigger things maybe not going
right after you know charges of genocide
in Darfur but but escalating the charges
to progressively bigger things yes I
mean first of all I think you know the
main the main political moment here is
is the transition and the government is
taking care of that this the conviction
itself will provide some momentum to the
transition it's been needing a win for a
long time it's been somewhat stagnant
the economy has continued to shift on a
downward spiral essentially and people
in the streets really need some evidence
of progress for a first Sudan so this is
essentially shop soft shooing things to
say yes he's convicted 10 years and then
reducing it to two has has also appeased
the remaining NCP groups within within
government John Horner for the
International Crisis Group I'm gonna
leave you there for now I hope you'll
stick around we've got the news hour
coming up with Nastasia in a moment I'm
sure we want to talk to you further on
our breaking news this hour that the
former President of Sudan Omar al-bashir
has been sentenced to two years in jail
this was the moment in court
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
consternation in the court there as that
sentence was handed down for financial
irregularities the former presidents of
Sudan found with suitcases in his house
with foreign currency in them worth up
to a hundred and thirty million dollars
this is after he was deposed by
protesters in April but he's got his
supporters and they are growing in
number outside the court we've been
looking at this shot for a little while
now and the numbers have been growing
there is plenty of anger at the decision
from the court remembering that and
Haber morgen our correspondent told us
that a man who is in power for 30 years
he will have his supporters despite the
fact he was ousted by the people on the
street